Speaker 1: We've been covering the supposed
bankruptcy of Infowars conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones.
This is a very complicated topic, which involves
Alex Jones being the target of multiple lawsuits
and presumably going in the direction of him
owing people a bunch of money, including parents
of the victims of Sandy Hook.
And interspersed with this, I told you a couple
of weeks ago that Alex Jones has declared
bankruptcy and we and others immediately questioned
the timing of the bankruptcy.
And, of course, the useful nature of a bankruptcy
if you're trying to avoid paying anybody.
One of the great things to do is to say you
don't have any money.
Well, now Alex Jones is actually bragging
about $2 million donations that they received.
He says now they have $5 million in the bank.
And this is something that to me, it seems
like it would be very interesting to the bankruptcy
trustees.
Take a look.
Speaker 3: Yes.
What you must have made the donor mad.
I don't know who they are, where they are.
They could be in Japan, could be in the U.S.,
could be who knows where.
I appreciate them, whoever they are.
But hundreds of millions of dollars of Bitcoin
and the lower price back in 2016.
Never spent any of them and is now giving
us.
$1,000,000 in Bitcoin and you must have upset
them, whoever they are, because all part to
the left of the globalist.
They gave us $1,000,000 more on Saturday.
Only break that for you while you sit there
and say we're covering it all up and hiding
and in bank accounts and all this crap.
So.
Speaker 1: I mean, you don't even need a bank
account to hide Bitcoin to.
Actually.
Speaker 3: We no longer have $3 million in
the company, barely enough to make payroll
and operate my product.
We now have $5 million.
And guess what?
You must.
Speaker 1: So I'm sure this is something the
bankruptcy court would be interested in.
Bankruptcy trustees, the trustee overseeing
the Sandy Hook parents case, the Sandy Hook
families would be at very, very interested
in hearing about this.
You know, I sat next to one of Alex Jones
former attorneys on a flight recently.
I talked about this on the bonus show or maybe
it was on a livestream.
I don't think I've mentioned it on the podcast.
No attorney client privilege was breached
because it was publicly known that this lawyer
represented Alex Jones at one point.
It was quite a conversation.
And you know, Alex Jones on the one hand has
a whole area of controversy related to what
counts as free speech.
And that's controversial enough.
And when does the speech become defamatory?
And all of these things are kind of being
legislated right now.
The other side of this is this very strange
and suspicious bankruptcy.
And I don't doubt for a second that the bankruptcy
isn't justifiable in some way, but the timing
is just so suspect.
So suspect.
And now bragging about having $5 million.
Now, if you went to him, he would go for us.
5 million is borderline bankruptcy because
our payroll is so high and our costs to produce
all these various supplements is.
So I don't even know whether the supplements
are actually some people when they do products,
they don't buy a bunch of inventory upfront.
They're just kind of produced and shipped
on demand.
Dropshipping And we don't know the nature
of that business, but he would say this is
just barely enough to fund our operation.
It's not like now we're flush with cash.
We certainly don't have any money for the
Sandy Hook families, but this all stinks to
high heaven and it continues to point in that
direction.
And quite frankly, I don't know what the end
game is.
I don't know if Alex Jones genuinely believes
that these manipulations when it comes to
the bankruptcy and having cash and not in
Bitcoin donations and all of it, I don't know.
I don't know.
The other thing is whether there's someone
wrote to me and said, Alex Jones seems confused
about whether they got $1,000,000 in Bitcoin
or whether they got one Bitcoin.
Now, could he really be confused about that?
I don't think so.
Now, if he knows the value, listen, I have
absolutely no idea, but it would be an extra
funny thing on top of all of the scam that's
being run here.
If he actually got one bitcoin and not $1,000,000
in Bitcoin, one bitcoin worth about 30, 35
grand at this point in time.
I don't know what the future of this is, but
it all stinks and the grifting and the scamming
continues.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We have a packed Friday show for you today.
The David Pakman Show is an audience supported
program.
You can sign up for a membership at join pacman
dot com.
You can use the coupon code.
Obama na o bomb.
That's 0bamna to get a discount at join pacman
dot com.
You'll get the bonus show.
You'll get the commercial free audio stream.
You'll get the commercial free video stream.
You'll get priority access during viewer townhalls
and on and on and on.
Sign up at join pacman dot com.
Let's hear from people in the audience.
The audience is why we do this without the
audience.
I'm a guy with a mic and the mic might not
even work if there were no audience.
We do calls via discord.
You can find our discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord.
We are going to go first to Nico from I believe
it's New Haven, Connecticut.
Nico, welcome.
Oh, boy.
Nico from New Haven, Connecticut.
Welcome.
Niko, you're on the air.
And Niko is gone